[Music]
i need my costume back and i want it
back am i important to you i'm gonna do
better i'm not even sure i want to do
this anymore clone i need your expertise
i'm here for you i thought mark would be
here tonight every one of these [ __ ]
in the previously on being all me me me
me me maybe if you didn't lose your
powers except rex
[ __ ] and battle beast using three
types of pin colors for your
investigation when one black pen and
colored highlighters are an option also
the red ink is under the black ink
meaning these circles came before the
word blood which is just a dumb way to
take notes this uninspired yet framed
original artwork what's important going
full rick sanchez you never go full rick
sanchez you're going to be in
what started out as a cute title card
gag has now morphed into an
anxiety-inducing slap bet even in the
real world my heart rate increases every
time someone says
keep an eye on that
an eye keep an eye on a gushing wound
how about pressure how about giving
pressure there you go find out what kind
of blood she can take show wants me to
believe that with all the preparation
cecil is making for an eventual showdown
with omniman that he's completely
overlooked the medical needs of the
security guardians of the globe how are
they even operating on him right now
even if they have some sort of special
vultromite surgical tools this does
raise the question is he or is he not
thank god whatever tore him up is sharp
i'm sure the reason for this statement
has something to do with making it
harder to put all the bits back together
but since all my experience with the
case of sharp v dull has to do with
kitchen knives it feels like the
doctor's worried about the quality of
his fillet six days how was mark popping
up off the table like a doorbell just
rang in his pizzas here he just had a
hole through his abdomen a few days ago
don't say he heals super fast he's still
got bruises on his face so his stomach
must still be healing what's more
interesting to me is why he would do it
so much of what's going on here between
cecil and nolan is bubbling right under
the surface we know these two characters
are hiding the most secrets and they
both are trying to game each other that
hostile dynamic turns this seemingly
simple conversation into a battle of
wits and i'm loving every second of it
start over treating a relationship like
a video game i'm just trying to start
over with amber you know i understand
the goal but i do not understand the
method you want to show her you're
serious by blocking your best friend on
a visit to a college you know little to
nothing about show highlights the fact
that it is constantly overshadowing the
butt if you can create and disappear
doors it will do you really need to pack
ever why not manifest a new outfit each
day from some pine cones instead of
lugging around all this luggage a normal
life a house a husband kids i see your
kids and raise you in overprotective
parents with outdated expectations when
you need to fly to another country you
don't flap your arms flappy arm shaming
dramatic much
i'm sorry i'm not you're being a jerk he
was being both dramatic and a jerk but
he was also making an argument
summarizing a conceptual framework for
addressing the limitations of human
longevity so instead of just calling him
an [ __ ] you could have responded with
a counter-argument highlighting why you
think replacing hearts with carburetors
is a bad thing in the end this sin comes
down to amber being a dick to
constructive academic debate being this
captivated by a water fountain i'm
serious i think this is what i want mark
says this after completing a series of
activities all in the quad i mean at
least go vet the cafeteria don't blame
me when you get to your first lunch and
realize the only choices are a
compressed chicken patty a melon based
fruit cup and a giant milk machine that
likely never gets cleaned you know when
you start a sentence with i think you
automatically murder 90 of any romance
in it and when you over explain mark's
crimes against passion you murder the
last 10 percent in this shot we see
amber marker up close and personal with
what's left of funny doug then in this
shot after they've taken a step back new
bystanders have found their way between
our guys and discount robocop meaning
that these two ran into harm's way just
so they could fall down running out of
harm's way save them if you want but
some people are already lost where the
hell did you go the tension created by
the whole marx double life causing
relationship problems feels so forced
while it's not entirely unbelievable it
is unbelievably frustrating you said you
wanted to start over oh this is
definitely
getting a signal in the middle of the
[ __ ] forest those are normal levels
for monster girl
she has a curse not a disease robot is
still slow dripping these medically
necessary details instead of just giving
them a full report and this doctor is
still treating monster girl's injuries
as if she's a normal person why isn't
cecil giving him the full report so i
take it we won
when you have a character whose only
facial expression is an awkward smile
you're bound to have some strange
moments did the creators really think
tom hanks would be okay with these dead
eyes nolan struck first is he analyzing
everyone else's costume to confirm this
this entire sequence of analyzing fabric
is fabricating facts for the sake of
sewing the plot together i feel gross
i'm taking a shower you feel gross so
you're taking a shower at the college
dorm to feel
cleaner improper placement of an exit
sign feel better than ever almost like
before i lost my powers maybe i should
get my ass kicked more often then rejoin
the team at guardians hq when your
powers have mysteriously miraculously
and obviously returned but the show
doesn't want to talk about that right
now
going ankle deep into sewer water to
save someone you [ __ ] one time behind
a boat house also why not call your
buddy before you descend into the stinky
pits of human waste or shoot a quick
text perhaps going low bro smells like
butt not the good kind well is anyone
concerned that the people at this party
are totally frozen in place is there
another bad guy lurking in the shadows
why is no one moved can't be lazy
animation it can't it's funny how
quickly things can fall apart
one day it seems like you have all the
time in the world and then the next
it's
gone for the love of john mayer nolan
just say what you need to say show is
really playing hard to get to the bottom
of nolan's subterfuge
i i can't hear you i'll see you back at
rick's dorm william is clearly terrified
and running for his life and mark thinks
i'll see you back at rick's dorm as an
appropriate response i know the power of
owners is strong with this one but the
show is straight up making it seem like
he's willing to let william die here
hole does not contain glory
i can't hear you hey
let me up [ __ ] if this is some joke
or some weird sex
i'm not the mood you're going to be
beautiful
you're going to be
i don't get a bp start two large bore
ivs sailing wide open type and cross for
10 units give me four units of o
negative down there stat drop an ng tube
and get dr benton in here
no place for a pediatrician mark
mark
mark
mom
oh hi mark
and no sex
no sex are you insane what about school
or college your mom goes to college you
can't save the world samantha
you think you could do these things but
you just can't nemo how does a machine
have emotions by subjecting myself to
erotic imagery